hello I'm good antibody my name is Danny
brokerage I will be speaking into you
today about a name is only in gene chip
technologies our next-generation
sequencing for a personalized medicine
and their music and also some research
that can be done results in techniques
you will notice that as my reputation
goals and show you some different
technologies molecular technologies and
apparatus which we don't different
companies those are the technologies
apparatus that we are using in our heart
there are several different types of
technology invective beliefs as well but
I'm showing you your specific apartments
because we have experienced observes
means so as a GGA lab which is directly
linked genetic analysis is authorized as
a medical genetics laboratory which is
equivalent to the clearer in the United
States but will also have the vegetation
as JP which is good laboratory practice
now which means that any research which
I've done in our God and can be
presented to the FDA so some rebar
technology companies and also pharma
company used on love in no leaking
facilities there a research and if there
is not Auto genetic lobby the world who
has drawers to accreditation because
it's very hard to mean danger but it got
to stand out in the lab is very very
high the first thing GG technologies
refer he'd like to present belong two
companies of cold
clear on how the x mark okay I mean what
it's good about their gene technology is
that it's very very flexible okay so
musings are genetic technology we design
and engage it which I'll show you in yet
I mean it could be in price very low in
the customers the time to perform is
very rapid I it's very accurate because
you kill pac-man SI which is the frozen
SI and very accurate my friend that is
very important about using this G chip
technology is that it's very very
flexible according to the specification
in of the in physician or genetic people
with a design in sa h however several
mutation in Chile good a different
technique lots of different disease the
invitation according to the needs and in
can change them with each other every
time we want to use it in so it's very
flexible I'm looking in design your own
fun and i'll show you some example of
the packages we design on world chips
and we are using them a lot the first
time that we design or follow a career
screen is Larry we don't know if you
know but Israel in doing a lot of lot of
genetic research our diagnostic in women
hair growth and careers currently more
than any in other places in the world
because there are a lot of different
ethnic groups in Israel a design in
cheek harbor 92 different mutation each
can cover if the verse 42 common
Israel and one where tests you can check
for all those diseases this is very
important answer we can avoid having
babies all girls in my genital is always
the first people to identify the
potential of this digit was also a
clinic opening it for daughter of sperm
and outside because they have to test
the donor to make sure that they don't
have that limitation because for
instance sperm donor which is popular
and it can be used 15 time over which
means the infant Harbor imitation we
actually will spread invitation in the
population you can see here in the slide
that they may find some career which
have those a limitation which is not a
problem for the women because they only
need to be checked to the specific
mutation to make sure the data not
insane also an imitation is there is no
problem you can see that the essay is
very accurately what you can see here is
attacking an essay result and you
confirm your culinary for Usher syndrome
type free any a taqman essay which are
out there I'm normal result we take
those nè sometimes I mean sequence and
buy some sympathy to confirm and drive
it in the existence of intentional could
see natural filtration were validated
and this is a common practice in our
laboratory every machine you can find
let me do coloring skinny undergo also
cycle sequencing so this is a short in
Rome this is a different type of carrier
mutation but we found a new property
goes is fall and again you can see in
the center circle thing to control
also usher isn't only type in one
location fixies italia either in sanger
sequencing so how do we know that those
with mutation are common in the
population you can see here this nuclear
family were two sisters in high in three
different in communication actually
there are four different mutation in one
nuclear family it is not very common
particularly that rose entation are very
frequently in preparation result in the
doors for ta2 disease ok if we check on
our population level you have a chance
about fifteen percent to harbor a one of
those mutation which is very hard why
you are doing those in screening next
panel is that I want to show you using
this technology of kimchi third eye it
is related to a predisposition to cancer
and specific now in for breast and
ovarian cancer most people are asking
like to do an energetic screen
regardless to open in lissenberg culture
so in someone we are tori to bless my
cancer me regular woman has a living
Saint chance in her lifetime until the
age of 72 we get dress on my cancer but
if he has a genetic background it could
be ninety percent ok so women want to
know if there are successful or not
because there's a lot of very thing you
gotta do is you can change your
lifestyle you can do all kind of medical
care and procedure I mean throwing up ok
so in the lovely design panel for
communication in the population
if a communication is not funny and
there is a cancer in the family we
recommend to do foreign gene sequencing
in countries operator and also if the
Cuban was found in the workings of them
also do in a keyword analysis on the
genetic background to adjust their
treatment so always people ask me how do
you know what are the communication in
the population so you don't know you
don't know if you don't do research 02
since the 20 participate in some of the
Richard Israel to define what of the
most communication and those are some
examples of papers or publish to define
what are the connotation and as you can
see here this is the panel of the 15
most common intention BL say 12 teams of
2 are skinny it's a very very popular in
and a little the screen thousands of
women in using this in gym chick and
because the price is very very low ok so
it's a less than 100 euro to scream
mutation so in a lot of women were
undergoing this way you can see that we
can find here the carrier this version
ossification and it's like that you see
here is a technical smile is to show you
that when we develop a new panel of the
mutation and we want to make sure that
all the taqman sa works fine but in
order to make sure that they work fine
you need a positive control unit but
sometimes you don't have all the totally
in control delay when you start the
panel so what we do we synthesized in a
synthetic delay of about 1,000 experts
and we introduced in it the location
reported screen and ready Jesus
they get cheap inconsiderate or mutation
are found using this so we always have a
positive control to all our reaction we
have another panel but this is for
another very dirty cancer which is colon
cancer okay so prone cancer the very
genetically passed on to your offering
me and again in order to define what are
the communication in colon cancer Israel
now the research and you can see all the
papers that we participate in and we
define what was a communication in colon
cancer listen then it is I'm very 30
notes already 14 and most communication
that we are screening me okay to find
these people need to do curls copy we're
going reach the age of 50 or they can
write a bit because they are not in high
risk for colon cancer this isn't funny
people are career and so on and some of
the mutation are even rarer mutation but
they load the specific ethnic group like
non-hodgkin algae and so on as I told me
before any runs in the family history ok
Felicity for colon cancer and no
communication found what we do is Sanger
sequencing ok over the limitation if
it's a cheap ECC of fat wrote a italia
fat he screams appropriate regime to
make sure that there's no rare disease
related to this cancer today it also
huge maximize sickles name in order to
me screaming not only 12 g but several
genes related to service console ok so
we have in our lives in mexico 500 which
is in latest apparatus alumina in
gave this world and it's very good to
use it we have a panel of 47 different
genes related to brace the line economy
concern and we can strain and generated
to both growth kind of cancer i will
show you some example how engines this
panel okay in family where it is several
people in the family has cancer but no
communication found and this is the
family entry screen for the 47 generally
found annotation is a faulty one its
unique related to colon cancer after we
found this gene on another patient
differently James like 40 actually those
mutation Alana are now added to the
common mutation in which our skin and
easily the next slide is to show you
that sometimes life is complicated this
is a family were in the same families
you have breast cancer but they also
have colony council occurring so when he
went to thank all this did you know
which Jing to scream so we came to our
laboratory in screen in 47 June all
together and we found the emirate one
mutation related to z khan concern which
is hnpcc and found the location in z XR
c c to g mitch is related to z and
breast and brain cancer now all the
other numbers in family can be tested on
it to those intention to see if their
voice or not we also generated their
panel for communication which are
related to a from a failure in a lot of
women are taking birth birth control in
appearance over half problem is
pregnancy or well there are introducing
you have traditionals and sometimes is
related to their population status and
so we develop tunnel between how
nine most connotation in all the factors
in which are no it will be involved in
said from roses and we are stranger than
all the time you can see here it all
women refer scream and were found to be
you know you have a one of the rotation
now that can be treated a according and
as I said before a sometimes a tumor in
her advice is any need to identify
genetic background of the tumor you need
to decide what will be the best way to
treat James is what we call lesson on
medicine in cancer and resolves are all
kind of several a demonstration which
could be in front you too Merc the first
and most common are somatic mutation
mutation which are not found is a
grenade of the rest of the body but only
in the tumors and there are several
genes which are very common to harbor
results kind of mutation that we give up
Ava's near Athens Rome paraffin skin
cancer chaos in chronic anxiety of egfr
easy non-cancer I mean screaming
communication and they're using panel of
EDG chip increases our table screening
annotations in colon cancer to decide
what we be the best treatment to give
them in the endless and chaos in six
occasionally generally identified
limitation which actually defined that
they will not benefit from this keynote
RPM to with a different filter
here's a full-time apparatus digit is
also a quantitative assay and you can do
in time pcr on it and to find the
expression of gene especially in tumor
suppressive keeping screen several
Eugene in advance you can see that
several June are being tested it to see
the expression and according to the
expression of the gene you can even see
if pass rate is working it final note
i'm just we're in a chemotherapy now i'm
moving to a different gene chip
technology ok which is also aimed to
scream the genetic makeup of the tool in
order to hedge their encourages to
decide what will be the best way to
create those pension now this a new
energy technology was developed by a few
clicks and i will show you in it in a
minute I just want to go over the
rationale for this injection technology
and other paper in the end of the 2013
in nature genetics about the fact that
in tumors and very in the copy number
variation that they have and somatic
mutation rate and if they actually said
that some of the conscience have a lot
of copy number variation in them and
some of the cancer types have a lot of
somatic mutation and is a leading the
apparatus will create scream both
wrongful unite evasion at once
ultimately say Ariel help divert in one
chickens out it's very good because all
those very password can be tested them
to see in which come from chemotherapy
is best for this place ok so this range
in chip which is called uncle Stan ok we
can screen 900g to see copy number
variation I mean
46 in somatic mutation what you see here
in this slide is a copy number variation
over two marrow which is normally okay
so this is the Roman harder than our
normal and when you showed me the next
slide how its look when it's not alone
now you can see that there's a lot of
copy another inspiration a lot of
chromosomes ok so this tumor ok is a
very unstable so sometimes you find
their small very big activation of copy
number and you want to see exactly which
gene exists in this puppy number
deletion I can see if you need to adjust
your chemotherapy and also to see with
somatic mutation in this tumor hub in
this one husband in chief of an
imitation I'm three chemotherapy could
readjust to that then I will see a two
samples the top one this one is a lung
cancer but you have a lot of meaning see
this copy nomination and this is another
lung cancer patient the tumor which we
got on a fape supper but there's not a
lot of copy number variation and we show
the slider before all so this is the top
one is a rockin activation resistance is
the bottom one it has grown almost in
iteration which mean that the upper line
okay the tumor is very unstable and will
be very very aggressive okay another one
is stable tumor like a treatment could
be adjust accordingly the upper one they
also were found to robber whiskey a
chaos mutation which is actually the
reason why it's not subscribe Berlin so
now there are colleges is treating this
patient know exactly a
what chemotherapy entity where they
freed I'm Jim chip technology also
another way where we can do in digital
PCR which means that we can identify
very rare in United Nation event okay
and i will show you only as oh there's a
lot of example a control you i do not
because we don't have enough time i'll
show you only one example then using
this technology it means i detect
everyone in reaction and divided it into
1765 smaller yummy chamber okay when
it's Chadron you actually get only one
molecule of duty okay so if there is a
rare denaturation you can find it ok so
here then one way of using it okay so
people have leukemia okay CNN they are
being treated with very clearly some of
the people will be resistant to clinic
because they Harbor a somatic mutation
is 23 152 I creates a nice inspiration
if the mutation exists very people
cannot respond to climate and nearer in
example a patient okay we were in
treated least lyric when they did Sanger
sequencing torrents blood they did not
find any intention so they kept treating
his David okay after one here lineage
relapse okay I'm see me came back and
when they took is a to suppress any at
the time of the relapse and one year 84
Europe 900 digital PCR we found that
they actually the detention exists need
36 8 times already but it means that he
was never in actually no variation it's
not surprising that he did the a love
song Mitchell TCR is very very a
powerful tool to take somatic in
in addition it will become more and more
nutrient use now because there is the
was the paper that was published of
thinking two months ago in nature where
they found in ml is a tool common
mutation which are playing to the ml if
you find when we know that people are
going to develop an air and the way to
detection rotation because they are very
rare in the blood is by digital PCR
using the nature a physical thing it'll
take the fsp some time with cancer and
also in the screen in the tumor for an
uncommon attention you can see a panel
of all the genes of three XP if people
out and what we think screen with those
250 genes in full sequencing the deal
dark in the file if they retire to all
types of a console spoil affymetrix has
another AG check technology that we are
using we on a beard Florrick when women
are you pregnant and we want to see is
their formula is the health copy number
variation this is instead of doing
regular epigenetics people are using
this ugh where today I mean it's a very
cool in practice today in any proceeding
that it's very easy and according to
software to detect any copying
opposition okay I'm in order to do
confirmation which there's copy number
variation we developed a very graphic
real-time pcr analysis which is a
quantitative assay where we have
primaries in a region of interest and we
have father to a different law sign in
the genome and it repairs a patient in a
tour control DNA anything serious in a
copy lucky number loss or not and this
is a routine friendly traitor in our
laboratory is worth some of the gene in
the genome has a pseudogene okay which a
doesn't affect the way people live but
its effect the way there
you can be done for instance the GBA
which is responsible for Boucher in
which is new to the sequence it has a
poker game ps2 which is related to hnpcc
has actually gained and the kidney
disease thinkin Iran also route she
believes a neat design Pacific partners
where we can analyze only the range in
and identify a [ __ ] mutation in
description now i'm going to go over to
next-generation sequencing and show you
how we use it to identify novel
denaturation which are a not farm by
regular sequencing of Sangha of common
Beijing when there is existing family
and the G which is related to this live
did not know for instance we are using
as a certain fraud in newly annexed 3500
ok a professor son with this field from
television Medical Center has a patient
which he thought that odd short QT
syndrome he did the secret signal with
the private colony in a James but no
mutation were found so within exome
sequencing which meant that recipients
the 20,000 in the gym and look for other
different patient and some northern
intention founding gene which were not
known to be associated with keynote I
track short kitty like this gene I mean
you can see the next slide in lemoore
several other jeans apple from as well
we're young very research on in position
are not easily this data to generate
anak marcin to research in to see the
effect in cardiovascular disease we are
the panel where he screamed 72 genes
which are no need to involve in
cardiovascular disease in screen
hologram or part of independent a it
denied from the calendar is the
physician in order in short on royal 15
and forever living in sudden death
syndrome very simply you can screen also
again to see if those people are in
funky those baby Jesus it exists that we
are finding all the time people who have
mutation when we do Sanger sequencing to
confirm those locations SFI rain which
also i want you to cardiovascular
disease and also the ntl the chapter
which is in connecticut is very high
cholesterol rejected in some people can
have it will also have heart disease not
so the mdr1 I'm gonna see to tha chain
Oh the photography published when
colleagues those funny in this slide I'm
showing you a different project ok where
a professor Ravenna turned on from the
hospital at the family well as they have
failure is a broad nerd it can develop
okay so no sexual information visit
family means they screaming several
genes which are relate to a known to be
associated with normal patient found the
big c GH copy number variation Georgie
no no nutrition were found so we did
exome sequencing and that filed a novel
gene in which could be related to this
phenotype in cm8 and we can see that the
mutation in secondary family only the
people which are affected this is the
family responsibilities crazy ultimate
ocean were homozygous ok we will need
opening the literature we found out the
journals and not at mass of this Jean
Lemire
and the stereotype is actually he has
probably need it produces very very
cheese in naming our children close to
what we found okay so only the time
listen general alaman another thing he
needs is going out to publication where
alumina has a lot of leery of chefs
panels for screening jeans you think
these are valid for dizzy cardiomyopathy
dirty disease in me clinical exome and
so on when you can do that accorded or
on demand it's very a convenient into
music now I'm going to show you a
different kind of gene chip technology
which is a news mostly for research but
also in beginning in typical mean for
diagnostic this is screaming for micro
early in my career I can be news as
biomarkers in several phenotype okay
money automatic as a district where you
can scream in over two thousand five
hundred different no micro remain to see
their expression there you know that the
matter main control the way a Djinn are
expressed okay so if you'd see different
in the expression of infinite microarray
different phenotype it could be related
to jade and won't blame if you lead to
how to treat and so on we will show you
one example okay so this is a macaroni
in chip that we'd evening is a group
from an area hospital and could see the
day to claim some new profile okay for
me number the legacy patient okay I mean
compared amazing Michael Harmon
expression and you can see that some of
the micro renee has fall forward
expansion and some of them were only a
32 sent in expression so there is a huge
difference now you follow up close
macaroni
see if they are related to gene which
can control this down in front another
thing which are reacted to in personal
medicine and also research is
epigenetics epigenetics is in cotton is
controlled by the Ephraim application
already way directly on certain genes
promoters in another region in order to
identify is very differently methylation
dinner music we supply in sequencing or
great salt into a fight with cyber
sequencing identify different even
methylation where the seed is converted
into tea and so on but we can also heal
very young on the connections of the
same using the new generation sequencing
and this is only genome never and you
can use up where when we this is me this
is just slide to show you got the
president Paris who houses noble path in
peace came to visit a lot he was
supposed to stay in 10 minutes
inconsistent world in schedule but after
entering our rod he stayed two hours to
work with us cousin was very impressive
all technologies I'm very in that world
learning lab and with this I will stop
by talking and if there are any question
I will be happy to really try anything
Angela
ok so I see that there is no question at
this time so very inefficient way we can
in finish the presentation now